foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to Cloud next
my name is aparna Papu and I lead Google
workspace
I'm absolutely thrilled to be here with
you
workspace is the world's most popular
productivity Suite with over 3 billion
users and now over 10 million paying
customers
now businesses know how critical it is
to enable not just efficiency but
Innovation creativity and team
collaboration
all this while attracting the best and
the brightest of the next generation of
employees
employees who grew up using workspace
grew up using tools like Gmail Drive
docs slides me chat and all the other
workspace apps
a new study on the emerging Workforce
found that 75 of recent college
graduates prefer working in Google
workspace because it offers a more
advanced seamless way for teams to work
together
and 86 percent of recent grads said that
they prefer Google docs for
collaboration
so as you think about workforce planning
this is a critical data point to keep in
mind
our groundbreaking technology has made
it incredibly easy to collaborate in
real time with other people
and now with duet AI you can collaborate
just as easily in real time with AI
AI that can act as a coach a thought
partner source of inspiration as well as
an efficiency booster across all of the
apps of workspace
now as Sundar shared earlier duet AI is
generally available to Enterprises
everywhere as of today
our Cloud native architecture and deep
and long history with AI meant that we
were able to bring the power of Google's
most advanced large language models to
workspace in record time
so starting today you can leverage
Google's AI built directly into
workspace
it can help you write better maybe in
the form of an email reply or a business
plan
look your best in Google meet
visualize your ideas with AI generating
imagery
and get organized in Google Sheets and
much much more
now if you haven't experienced to add AI
in workspace yet and want to give it a
try I've got good news there as well
starting today we have a duet AI for
workspace trial that you can sign up for
directly using this URL
now if you're not already a customer of
ours and the idea of switching to a
brand new product sounds complex not
anymore
you or a team in your department can
start using workspace apps like meet
chat Drive dark sheets alongside your
existing Solutions today
thousands of companies and over 1
million users have experienced how duet
can transform their day-to-day work and
we're grateful for the feedback that
they're providing
these users span Global businesses large
and small educational institutions as
well as consumers
let's hear from some of them about their
experience with duet
[Music]
from igniting creativity during
brainstorming sessions to drafting
seamless Google Sheets templates we're
constantly finding innovative ways to be
more productive Ai and Google workspace
[Music]
duet Ai and Google workspace cut the
time it takes for me to respond to
emails in half that's a lot of your day
that's back for you to do subsequent
with it makes us look like a bunch of
superheroes
[Music]
AI
AI workspace in this enables us to open
up it better
trees can speak more freely we are able
to unleash the potential from more
people across the globe
[Music]
a long history of using the workspace
made it a lot easier for us to
participate security is not a choice in
the Department of Defense
duet AI undoubtedly helps adoremi's
bottom line it saves us time it saves US
money it makes people work faster more
efficiently more collaboratively and
just do things that in the past we never
would have been able to do
[Music]
it is really really inspiring to see all
of the neat things that customers are
doing already with duet
now let's look into the future
I'm excited to share our vision as well
as a preview into what we're launching
in the coming months
now I don't know about you
but sometimes it feels like there's just
not enough time in the day
we have to go through so many emails sit
through meetings documents follow-up on
action items
that keeping up in a 24 7 world of
business feels daunting
what if you had an intelligent assistant
that dramatically reduced that burden
now there have been many attempts at
this in the past but this time
three things are different that may
Google uniquely positioned to deliver on
this opportunity
first Googles continue deep investment
in cutting-edge research and AI have
generated language and multimodal models
that have surpassed our imaginations in
terms of their ability to synthesize
information
generate compelling responses and
perform complex reasoning tasks
second
to make these llms truly useful in your
daily life they actually need real-time
access to relevant contextual data
like information in your drive or Gmail
or conversations in a meeting and the
actions that you took as a result of
that information
with workspace not only is that data
readily available because we're Cloud
native
but it is also protected with security
access control and privacy
finally
AI must act in a responsible and safe
way
this is not just about having deep
commitment but it's actual real world
experience with AI is what it takes to
get this right
Google has been responsibly bringing
helpful AI to life for over a decade
so let's see how we can bring all of
that to bear in our daily lives and
making it more efficient allowing you to
focus on what really matters
let me invite Christina on stage to show
you how this works
thank you of harna so here's a common
task that anyone in finance will
understand let's say I am on the finance
team and I get an email from my boss
that she needs a deck on the Q3
performance by 8 AM tomorrow it is 5 p.m
and I have plans tonight
so instead of going through the arduous
process of sifting through four cash
sheets p l docs MBR slides emails from
the regional sales leads catching up on
meeting notes I can simply ask duet AI
in the new side panel to do the heavy
lifting for me
as you can see from my prompt create a
summary of Q3 financial performance
duet summarizes all of this great
information from Gmail and Google drive
to save me a ton of time
and because my data is my data and
workspace provide protects users privacy
I know that this summary is grounded in
only the files and emails that I have
access to
now in the past I would have had to
manually cut and paste this information
into this deck but in the future duet AI
will do this for me duet can create the
starter deck based on these specific
files so that I can focus on adding my
point of view and of course get to my
dinner plans thank you back to you of
harna
[Applause]
thanks Christina
that's really impressive I especially
love how duet cites the content sources
giving you more confidence that the
generated content is actually grounded
on your data
now this was just one example but you
can see how it can apply to so many
complex tasks in every discipline
whether it's Finance sales engineering
and much more
so that made one aspect of our work
lives much better but what about a
different aspect
meetings let's get Dave on stage to show
us how duet can help
[Music]
thanks a forna before I jump in to
what's new with Google meet I'd like to
reflect on how far this product has come
over the past three years
I'll be honest at the start of the
pandemic meat wasn't ready to take on
the new world of remote and hybrid work
and many of our customers opted to use a
different meeting solution entirely
but since that time we've invested
heavily in meat launching hundreds of
new features and transforming it into an
Enterprise grade meeting Solution that's
deeply integrated into workspace
best of all customers are voting with
their feet and returning to meet
in fact Gartner peer insights has
recognized Google as a customer's choice
in unified Communications as a service
for 2023
what makes this award so special to us
is that it came from our customers who
choose to use Google meet over other
alternatives
so if you haven't tried meat lately I
encourage you to give it another look I
think you'll be blown away
but we aren't stopping here
let me show you six ways duet is
redefining Enterprise grade video
conferencing with new features rolling
out today through early next year
being clearly seen and heard is an
important part of any meeting but
sometimes things can get in the way like
poor lighting or a low quality webcam
with Studio look duet applies generative
AI to your camera's video feed in real
time to help fill in missing details
and to what will apply Studio lighting
to your video allowing you to change its
location color and intensity so you look
great in any setting
and Studio sound uses similar techniques
to reconstruct your voice to recording
studio quality
let's take a listen
ER
[Music]
exceptions
that sounded important but I could
barely understand it let's apply Studio
sound and see what happens
can you hear me clearly stay on schedule
it's critical you'll be update the
figures in section 11.7 by 90 minutes or
pretty amazing right
language barriers can also be a blocker
to effective meetings with automatic
translated captions duet knows that I
prefer English and in real time it
translates your first Speaker from
Swedish to English
and our second speaker from Chinese to
English just like a universal translator
and thanks to our latest advancements in
generative AI we're adding support for
over 300 language pairs
now let's talk about presentations
you've already learned how duet can help
you create inspiring presentations in
Google Slides when it's time to present
duet now helps you bring your notes to
life with real-time teleprompting which
uses live speech recognition to follow
your voice and guide you through your
notes one line at a time
as a meeting participant I find the best
meetings are the ones where I can pay
full attention and meaningfully engage
in the conversation
but if you're also taking meeting notes
it's really tough to do that
with the new take notes for me feature
duet captures notes action items and
even video Snippets in real time
if you join late duet will display a
summary of what's happened so far and
you can even ask duet questions to get
more context without interrupting the
call how cool is that
when the meeting ends DeWitt sends out a
beautiful note stock powered by Google
Docs you can play back video clips of
important moments or even ask duet
additional questions about the meeting
okay take notes for me is cool but what
if you have more meetings than you can
possibly attend
to illustrate this point let me show you
Thomas kurian's calendar but please no
photography as this is strictly
confidential
okay as you can see legal asked us to
remove some of the details but you you
get the idea his schedule is packed and
many times it's double booked sound
familiar
well with a 10 for me you can now send
duet to the meeting
perhaps you have questions or comments
that you'd like service in the meeting
on your behalf
you can type them in beforehand
and when the meeting begins duet will
ensure everyone sees it so it's part of
the conversation
and you'll get a copy of the note stock
when it's over so you know what happened
and if they gave you any action items
with a 10 for me you can truly be in two
places at once
[Applause]
well I can't wait to have to attend some
meetings for me I know that regularly
connecting with my co-workers is
essential to functioning as a team
but it doesn't always have to be a
formal meeting sometimes we just need an
easy way to jump on a call to talk
through an important problem quickly to
informally connect and catch up
that's why we're introducing huddles in
Google Chat
huddles are audio first impromptu
Gatherings powered by meat that help
distributed teams come together in real
time without having to jump into a
separate scheduled meeting
you can easily start a huddle directly
in a space or a group chat
and speaking of chat we've invested
heavily here as well and the Next
Generation Workforce have embraced it as
a means to get things done
whether that's chit chatting with the
colleague making progress on a team
project or increasingly a channel for
organization-wide communications from
company leadership
here at next we're announcing a major
evolution in chat with a ton of eagerly
anticipated features I'd encourage you
to attend the what's new in chat
breakout session to hear all about them
but there's just one I have to talk
about
we are bringing duet to chat to provide
updates insights and proactive
suggestions across your workspace apps
you can even follow up on tasks and
assigned actions
let me show you what I mean
see I forgot about an action item from
an important meeting
to what in chat will proactively notify
me before it's due and when I'm done I
can resolve it right from within chat
updating the associated meeting notes
and letting everyone know I've got it
covered
that's just some of the new features
we're announcing across meet and chat
here at next back to you aparna
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you Dave
it's amazing to see all the ways Duets
going to help people have more efficient
and effective meetings or maybe not even
addendum at all
I personally can't wait to jump into a
huddle and start planning our next big
event
now it's time to see all these features
in action
please help me welcome Harris on stage
to show us how all this comes together
in a marketing scenario
[Applause]
thanks aparna hi everyone as a marketer
I know firsthand how much time consuming
work it takes to convey the value of a
product to customers today we're going
to see how do it AI can make all of our
Lives easier
meet Quinn Quinn is a marketing manager
at symbol a fair trade manufacturing
company she leads a global team and is
currently responsible for the company's
biggest product expansion
first thing every morning Quinn grabs
her phone checks what the day has in
store she sees lots of unread emails
from the leadership team it's going to
be a busy day
so she hops on her laptop and sees the
duet has summarized an overnight email
thread from her team in Europe that is
25 deep enabling her to catch up quickly
but likely would have taken her an hour
of reading trying to figure out what's
going on is summarized in seconds but
now Quinn needs to quickly figure out
what action items have already been
identified but duet is already on it and
suggests a list of action items to help
instead of wasting valuable time trying
to figure out what needs to get done
across the team with duet Quinn could
immediately focus on getting to work
and next Quinn asked duet to help her
write a detailed reply evenly
Distributing the key action items across
their team let's see what we get back is
do it works its magic over here
and it's processing and there we go just
what Quinn was looking for saving her
even more time Quinn sends that email
and now she needs to get to work that
sales training isn't going to happen by
itself or is it
sales team in South America needs to get
ready for customer meetings and it's
Quinn's job to train and provide them
with the material they need to get those
orders coming in
Quinn asked duet to create a calendar
invite with the sales team in South
America
Quinn's validating the suggested
calendar invite to make sure it's
exactly what she wanted
and as she's approving it she realizes
she doesn't need to think about anyone's
schedule finding a meeting room or
adding a meat video link to the invite
she definitely won't miss doing that
neither will I now Quinn needs something
to present to that sales team it took
the marketing team in the U.S a week to
create the sales presentation for the
initial release of the coffee line but
the South American markets are unique
and their customers have different
preferences in the past queen of wooden
spent hours if not days working with the
local team updating the presentation to
make it relevant for this local target
audience but she is a better way to get
what she's done needs done now not three
days from now so Quinn opens up her
slide presentation she selects the slide
she wants to edit types in the prompt
what she's looking for let's see
generate a slide based on the sales
training dock which is in her local
Drive
and wow just like that Quinn is going to
see how polished a new slide could look
and they were created with just a few
words this feels like magic but it's
duet
but she needs to make the image on this
slide feel relevant for her audience so
she asked duet to generate an image of a
coffee field with the Brazilian flag
blowing in the wind
Duets suggests four options and as
they're working to generate them she
sees the first one looks great she looks
at the newly created slide and is
excited to see that the generated text
images and speaker notes look like
something she would have crafted herself
and now she could focus on the sales
training instead of staying late at work
trying to finish this deck
Quinn has been so focused on working and
getting a week's worth of work done in
the morning she has a brief moment of
panic when she sees how messy her home
office is and right before she's about
to get on a call with the sales team but
don't worry Quinn duet has you covered
how about a custom virtual background to
help protect your privacy and celebrate
the sales team in Brazil which is
symbol's largest Workforce in South
America there's no scouring the internet
required
Quinn uses duet and meat to create a
unique background and in this example
she's showing a coffee shop with the
painting of the golden trumpet tree
which is Brazil's natural flower emblem
in just a few clicks
she's happy with that Quinn joins the
meeting and gets excited that she sees
hundreds of Sellers from across South
America joining from their homes and
symbols Regional Offices one of the
sales leaders in Brazil asked the
pricing question in Portuguese but Quinn
doesn't speak Portuguese that's no
longer a problem duet automatically
translated into English in real time and
translates our answer back into
Portuguese
duet has also been summarizing the
conversation and listing key action
items for the people who join the call
late or who were multitasking at the end
of the call do it also sends out a
summary of the call with all the action
items accomplishing in seconds would
have taken her at least 30 minutes in
post call work
but there were so many thoughtful
questions and requests from the sales
team during the call that Quinn wants to
capture this information in FAQ she
simply asked duet to do it and hits
enter and another helpful but
time-consuming task that would have
taken Quinn an hour more in the past is
completed in seconds and now that we
have that sales team trained what
product announcement would be complete
without a blog post sharing how
transformational this product is yes
these days even coffee needs to be
transformational
but a well-crafted blog post localized
across regions languages and can be time
consuming process but let's see how duet
can help since the product was already
announced in the United States Quinn
could leverage all that core messaging
in the original blog post but you'll
need to tailor the story to resonate
with customers in South America in order
to break through and have an impact
adding some local customer stories
imagery and Trends always drives more in
great engagement
so Quinn clicks on duet and asks it to
draft a blog post for the South American
launch based on existing U.S blog posts
and a file with customer stories as you
see she types it in she's pulling up a
file from her drive to other blog posts
and it pulls up the customer reference
file now duet AI goes to work and it's
generating
that blog post for her and wow with just
a few words do a crafted a solid draft
that also includes a customer quote
completing in second would have taken
her hours in the past
Quinn feels good about this content but
thinks the blog post is a little bit
long and could be even better if it was
shorter and more engaging so Quinn asked
you at AI to rewrite the draft with the
tone and length based on a previous blog
post from the region that she knows has
high traffic and engagement
there we go
she inserts that
since she's in docs Quinn can
collaborate easily and effectively with
others in the dock she invites them to
trusted stakeholders to make some
comments in the doc let's see she's
adding her stakeholders and then she's
going to type a note to them
requesting their feedback and know that
the blog post will be ready to go soon
Quinn wants to maximize the reach of
this message now and a new ad campaign
will do just the trick so Quinn prompts
duet to craft a few headlines based on
the blog post
let's see what she gets back here
Duets working it's magic and there we go
five headlines nice short catchy and
using the narrative from her blog she
can definitely use these headlines to
help amplify in symbols campaign
with the blog post in good shape Quinn's
team wants to get on a real-time status
update and see how all the preparation
is going one of her team members creates
a huddle in chat so Quinn can share the
progress she's been making
let's see they're all joining and she
wants to make sure that leadership and
the sales team know that everything is
ready to go to have a quick conversation
they're talking to each other she lets
them know they're ready to go and done
that was really efficient in meat the
team is really impressed and they can't
believe how she was able to create such
high quality work so quickly she
receives tons of Kudos from across the
business it's coming in fast that
feedback is coming in so fast that Quinn
needs some help keeping up with the
conversation but since she knows she can
interact with dueted chat she asks her
to summarize the thread for her so all
she doesn't have to go through reading
all those messages and just like that do
it was able to give Quinn uh a great
message and she was able to prepare for
this product launch in South America
stay ahead from competition and
capitalize on the massive Market
opportunity this level of speed and
efficiency and personalization simply
wasn't possible a few months ago and now
back to you corner thank you
thank you Harris for that Whirlwind tour
this might seem like sci-fi to some of
you but trust me that future is closer
than you think
I've been playing with early versions of
some of what Harry showed you myself and
have been truly Blown Away by how good
the generated outputs are
we're working really hard and getting
many of these features out to our
trusted testers income in the coming
months
with all of this Innovation at your
fingertips you can rest assured that we
keep your data protected private and
under your control at every point
as the world's most popular and secure
Cloud native communication and
collaboration Suite workspace was
designed from the very onset to keep
your data private and secure
for nearly 25 years Google has built
helpful secure products that give users
choice and control over their data it's
a Bedrock principle for us and continues
to be our top priority
generative AI does not change this so
what does this mean specifically for you
first and foremost your data is your
data the content that you put in to
workspace Services is yours we never
sell your data and you can delete or
export it at any time
second your data stays in workspace we
do not use your data to train the
underlying generative AI models in large
language models without your permission
third your privacy is protected
interactions with workspace features
like spam protection or autocomplete are
anonymized or aggregated with strict
privacy protecting features that keep
you in control
finally as a reminder your content is
not used for ads targeting Google does
not collect scan or use your content in
workspace services for advertising
purposes
I'd like to invite you Lee out to tell
us more about our unique approach to
data security and privacy
Banks of harna
security confidentiality and compliance
continue to be top of mind for our
customers from small businesses and
large Enterprises to schools and
governments and for good reason
last year cyber security attacks grew 38
with each data breach costing
organizations millions of dollars this
is a daily challenge for security and
compliance Professionals in addition to
the regulatory work that is getting more
complex across the world
you don't need to be a security expert
to notice security incidents in the news
that happen regularly
clear
that the sheer scale of modern attacks
and the sophistication of motivated
adversaries are something that Legacy
productivity Solutions can't keep Pace
with
but with workspace there is a better way
first are Cloud native zero trust
architecture
with workspace your data is stored in
the cloud which means there is no
persistent local data on end user
devices
just think about situations when those
devices are lost stolen or taken to
another country
access to data is verified with every
request and can be immediately revoked
with built-in zero trust controls
without having to rely on special agents
on devices
it might sound simple but the fact that
the data is in the cloud makes it much
easier for your security teams to
control access to it
job is more complex when confidential
files are distributed to thousands of
end user devices with a legacy solution
second
workspace apps run in any browser or
mobile apps
unlike traditional productivity
Solutions this means that users don't
need to use thick client apps that need
to be constantly patched and protected
from vulnerabilities and malware
all workspace apps can be accessed from
any browser including Chrome and our
native apps on Android and iOS devices
this is a large attack surface that your
it and security teams don't need to
worry about
third with workspace you have technical
controls to help you prevent third-party
access to your data
client-side encryption specifically
allows you to store encryption keys
outside of workspace in the country of
your choice ensuring that external
entities such as Google or foreign
governments cannot access your data
lastly
workspace runs on Google's Global
infrastructure your teams immediately
get the benefits of a reliable and
defense in-depth infrastructure that
we've built improved and secured for
decades for billions of our users
also means there is no on-premises
infrastructure that needs to be managed
updated and secured by your I.T and
security teams
but with security and confidentiality
the job is never done which is why we're
adding additional control for our
customers to help keep their data safe
built-in data loss prevention controls
can help you prevent confidential data
like customer and financial records from
falling into the wrong hands
but this requires the data to be
accurately classified which can be
complex and time consuming requiring
efforts from your security teams and end
users
to help address this we're bringing the
power of Google AI to help you
automatically and continuously classify
and label data in Google Drive
ensuring data is appropriately shared
and protected from exfiltration
administrators can customize this
capability to their unique needs by
training the AI model with examples of
content that are restricted confidential
and public so that the model can
automatically apply classification
labels without any human intervention
with an increase in hybrid work
employees are accessing data from
different locations and devices on a
more regular basis
provide your security teams with more
granular data protection controls we're
enhancing the data loss prevention and
drive with context aware controls
this level of granularity allows admins
to control the conditions such as device
location or security status that must be
met for users to be able to copy
download or print a document from Drive
this can help with scenarios where users
travel to a forbidden country or don't
keep their devices up to date and
secured
for customers that are looking for
another layer of data protection in
addition to supporting their Regulatory
and compliance requirements we are
further enhancing our client-side
encryption capabilities
CSE can help you prevent third-party
access from external entities such as
Google or foreign governments by giving
you the ownership and control over the
encrypting keys outside of Google
today we're introducing a number of CSE
enhancements including the support of
mobile apps in calendar Gmail and meet
the ability for admins to set CSE as
default for select organizational units
such as Finance or legal
guest access support and meet comment
support in Google Docs and the ability
for users to view edit or convert
Microsoft Excel files
Sovereign controls in workspace that
include CSE we can help you go beyond
essential data residency controls that
are available from Legacy productivity
providers and accelerate your journey to
a testable digital sovereignty by giving
you complete and sole authority over
your data
Sovereign controls provide a holistic
approach to digital sovereignty
first
software sovereignty allows you to work
without dependencies on provider
software to help you avoid vendor
lock-in
second
data sovereignty allows you to keep
control over residency encryption keys
and access to your data
today this includes control over where
your data is stored at rest
but later this year you will also have
the ability to control where your data
is processed in the European Union or
the United States
and lastly operational sovereignty
allows you to have visibility and
control over provider operations
today you can limit approved access to
us-based support but later this year
we're expanding this control so that
customers in the EU can also select
eu-based support
collectively
these security
confidentiality and compliance controls
can help commercial and public sector
organizations further reduce their data
security risks while supporting their
Regulatory and compliance requirements
across the world
back to you aparna
[Applause]
thank you Julie
it's great to see that the continued
Investments and Innovation on security
and compliance fronts are not only
helping our customers keep their data
safe and private but they're also a big
reason why Enterprise customers and
regulated organizations are switching to
workspace across the globe
all right
we've just walked through a ton of
innovation that's coming to workspace
some of these features are available
today and the rest will launch in the
next few weeks months and through the
rest of the co
some of these will go through the hands
of our trusted testers before we bring
them to Market next year
I'm incredibly excited about the
direction that we're taking but we're
not doing this alone we remain committed
to workspace being an extensible
platform
a platform that integrates third-party
apps that perform functions like
submitting expenses or filing for a
vacation managing complex projects
building creative content hosting
large-scale virtual events and much much
more
our partners make workflows seamless and
I want to thank them for extending
workspace in meaningful ways for all our
customers
now if you've been inspired by what
you've seen here and want to take the
next step in experiencing duet
then get started today with a duet AI
for workspace trial
this new SKU and trial is just the first
wave of bringing the power of duet to
all of our three billion users and 10
million workspace customers
I've never been more excited about the
future of collaboration and productivity
with AI front and center as a
collaborator that unlocks the full
potential in each of us
thank you for joining us and be sure to
check out all the workspace sessions
here at next
foreign